Speaker 1: Let's go next to Audrey in Georgia,
Audrey in Georgia.
You're on the air.
Speaker 4: Oh, hi.
I didn't expect for.
Did you see recently about the accidental
shooting involving a woman who meant to take
the woman of a man that was being arrested?
Speaker 1: Yes, we covered that earlier this
week.
Speaker 4: All right, I wanted to ask your
opinion on something.
What do you think should should be the outcome
for the police officer in this situation?
Do you think she should be charged with manslaughter?
Do you think they should?
Simply border from police service and let
her off the hook, what do you think?
Speaker 1: It's not for me to say she has
been charged with second degree manslaughter.
I believe I just read.
Speaker 4: Yes, yes.
Speaker 1: And so it's going to be up to a
court to to decide that my opinion about what
the outcome would be was that she is not going
to see a guilty criminal verdict in a court
of law.
My prediction was on the criminal side, it
will probably plead out and there will be
a big financial settlement civilly.
That's my prediction.
But I think that now that the second degree
manslaughter charges come forward, we just
have to let you know, I don't have all of
the evidence.
I've seen the video.
I've seen commentary.
We need to go through the process.
Speaker 4: Yeah, I was talking about somebody
else earlier, I think most people can agree
that this this was, you know, an accident.
Speaker 1: It's just now the thing about calling
it an accident, I think that there's a better
way to say it.
Her intention did not appear to be to shoot
the victim.
Yeah.
Whether we say that that's an accident or
we say this is negligence by someone whose
job is supposed to be to know, do you have
your Taser or your gun in your hand?
We're talking about the same thing, but the
implication of the words we use is very different.
So for me, you know, when we say it was an
accident versus we say it was a negligent
action by an officer, it's different.
And that's why I'm careful about using that
word.
Speaker 4: Oh, yeah, of course.
Thank you for correcting me on that.
But what I'm interested in is like the further
action that should be taken to prevent these
things from happening in the future.
Yeah, so as we were talking about this yesterday
in and the server and somebody pointed out
that the service weapons that they use in
the Minnesota police force, the Taser that
they specifically used, mace made by Exxon,
is extremely similar, in shape, in color and
in weight to their service pistol.
And it doesn't surprise me learning that that
of something like this would happen.
Speaker 1: Well, you know, there's another
aspect.
Let me let me ask about another aspect.
Maybe you know this, Audrey, maybe you don't.
Is it accurate that officers carry their gun
and Taser on their like the gun is always
on one side dominant versus non dominant,
and the Taser is always on the opposite.
Speaker 4: And I saw an interesting analysis
of this.
Yeah, I obviously I'm not a psychologist,
so I don't I don't know if this is true or
not, but an analysis from a police psychologist
who had said that under stressful situations,
sometimes your motor cortex can can do the
opposite action of what you were actually
commanding it to do so that there could be
a psychological explanation for this.
I don't know the validity of that.
Yeah, that I don't know about.
That's coming from a police psychologist,
right?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I know that that I don't
know about either.
I think that I am very comfortable having
watched the video in saying the officer did
not intend to shoot the victim.
But that to me does not tell me what I need
to know in order to determine what should
happen in a court of law.
And that's what the system is now going to
have to adjudicate.
Speaker 4: Yeah, personally, I think she should
be convicted of manslaughter simply for the
fact that imagine that there was this was
a minority and in this exact same situation,
I believe that they would be convicted of
manslaughter.
Speaker 1: You're saying a minority officer.
Speaker 4: Yeah, in a similar situation, I
think they would likely in a court of law,
not be seen as fairly as a white or privileged
police officer got, and I don't think that
it would be fair for them to get charged and
convicted and for somebody else not to.
Speaker 1: OK, very good.
Audrey, I appreciate it.
Speaker 4: All right, thank you very much.
All right,
Speaker 1: let's see who else we can we can
hear from today.
How about we speak to.
Let's go to Tony from California, Tony from
California.
You're on the air.
Speaker 3: Hello.
Oh, yeah, I was in class.
I have a question regarding Joe Manchin.
Sure.
Last weekend when he was talking about.
When he said that.
What was it you will now vote to eliminate
or reform the filibuster, right?
Or we can.
All right.
Yep, and I have mixed thoughts about what
he meant by weekend, OK, such as maybe by.
Nuking a filibuster for certain types of legislation.
OK, or just for any type of reform.
So I'm just wondering what you think about
that.
Speaker 1: I think at this point it's very
clear that Joe Manchin is not willing to do
anything at all to change the filibuster is
the way I'm interpreting it.
So for me, I don't even find it necessary
to analyze what would be on one side of the
line and on the other side of the line.
I'm not getting the impression he's willing
to do anything.
OK.
Do you disagree?
Speaker 3: I don't know.
I really don't know.
I mean, I've only.
Been getting into politics like last year.
Yes, I really don't know anything.
Speaker 1: I mean, listen, I get the impression
that at this point, Joe Manchin knows that
he has the potential to have a lot of negotiating
power by being the guy that might keep Joe
Biden from getting 50 votes and keep him at
49.
I think he knows that.
I think he's enjoying it.
And I think that everything I hear from him,
including recently saying the January 6th
riots, made him realize the importance of
bipartisanship, almost like he's allowing
the hostage takers to to change his mind.
I'm very concerned by what I'm hearing from
from Joe Manchin.
I can't imagine him being an ally on any of
the tough things, on the easy things.
Sure, he'll vote with Democrats, but I'm very
worried about Manchin.
Thank you.
My pleasure.
All right, thanks to everybody who called
in, we are going to go to a break.
We will take calls again very soon.
And as always, I'm sorry I was not able to
get to everybody.